le saut à la perche en question par les
autorités sportives la chasse aux
records que se livrent les meilleurs
athlètes du monde dont les français a
amené à s'interroger sur l'efficacité
des mesures concernant les auteurs des
bars entre 5 mètre 85 mètre quatre-vingt
la différence est faible et il paraît
difficile de l'évaluer
alors avant les championnats d'europe
d'athlétisme et qui doivent avoir lieu
le week-end prochain à lille
les responsables de l'organisation se
sont penchés sur ce problème
dominique le glou ce sam est de 81 1
c'est le nouveau record du monde du
soviétique vladimir poliakov aintabi la
thur électronique équipé d'un mini
ordinateur on affiche la hauteur demandé
par l'athlète élabore électriquement se
place à la bonne hauteur en aucun cas
cet appareil n'est officiel il ne fait
que faciliter le travail des juges qui
doit après le saut contrôler la mesure
comment peut-on sans risque d'erreur
mesurer 1 centimètres de différence
entre la performante deux athlètes
méritent elles toutes ces performances
ont été accomplis lors de compétition
très importante des contrôlés par des
officiels compétent pour mesurer la
hauteur de la barre on utilise une toise
et une toise qui est utilisé dans toutes
les compétitions une cloison avec leur
bec télescopique qui touche la partie
supérieure de abords de la tête prend
son élan sur une piste et pizzas kazan
1-1 butoir et autour du butoir la
surface et à une poignée tri absolument
identique à nationale au niveau de la
piste d'élan et on pose la toise à ce
niveau la hauteur et mesurée à partir de
la verticale du butoir
donc les juges toise la verticale du
butoir cherche la barre dessous le
règlement permet l'athlète de modifier
de repousser les poteaux jusqu'à 60 cm à
sa convenance
et si la planimétrie de la base des
poteaux n'est pas parfaite
il est possible d'avoir après une
tentative réussie
après mensurations nouvelle d'avoine
différentes c'est arrivé plusieurs fois